[Musique]
il ya des gens qui engagent leur vie
vous avez vous engagez d'une autre façon
mais de façon moins dramatique dans un
film qui n'est pas si léger qu'il en
al'air finalement qui s'appelle l'âge la
joie de vivre de rejet guillot qui est
ici présents et vous jamais monsieur qui
s'appelle monsieur charme
drôle de nom
c'est un an c'est un nom qui leur
présentent bien je pense que c'est un
personnage
qui ne se sert pas de son charme et qui
en a tout le monde dit que c'est un ours
mais c'est un homme assez charmant qui
représente assez bien face qu'est
l'homme en général l'homme vieillissant
l'homme qui n'attend plus grand-chose de
l'existence qui voudrait que ça s'arrête
assez vite et qui finalement
dans le chemin pour précipiter les
événements trouve une autre raison de
vivre une raisons de survie plus
exactement et qui s'attache à cette
survie
comme un coquillage s'accroche un rocher
et qui trouve une raison de continuer
malgré que leur approche alors vous vous
dites souvent que ce que vous aimez
c'est les auteurs et sadek amin vraiment
les rencontres alors que c'est souvent
plus tôt théâtre que vous les trouvez
vous le disiez à la halle à l'occasion
de la sortie de toto le héros vous
disiez d'autant que le cinéma actuel
donne souvent dans la dérision le je
m'en foutisme le laisser aller et que je
ne vois pas trop ce que j'irais faire là
dedans alors il ya deux exceptions
j'imagine qu'ils avaient considéré que
régis guiot on était une âpre et auto
après le très beau film de jaco van
dormael je me disais je ne retrouverais
certainement pas avant de disparaître
un autre film qui me qui m'attache qui
me où je trouve vraiment une raison de
vivre avec lui pendant les quelques mois
qui précèdent le tournage et j'ai trouvé
ce très beau scénario de roger guillot
qu'il m'a envoyé par la poste tout
simplement un jour
et avec son numéro de téléphone j'ai lu
ce scénario en deux heures de temps
j'étais je me pendant pendant la lecture
du scénario d'ailleurs je me disais on
s'en tiendra pas ça ne tiendra pas
jusqu'au bout et finalement ça a tenu
jusqu'à la dernière page et j'étais
évidemment très très ému très
bouleversée de d'avoir ce cadeau
j'étais en tournée à ce moment là et je
me suis dit j'ai téléphoné tout de suite
à roger millions je lui ai dit écoutez
si vous faites le film je le ferai avec
vous avec une et à très grand bonheur
alors quand vous lisez comme ça un
scénario de quelqu'un a tenu que vous ne
connaissez pas qu'est ce qui se passe à
dire c'est une sorte immédiatement de
deux projections dans le rôle dont vous
sentez qu'il vous sera dévolue c'est la
cohérence du sénat lancer ses
différences du seigneur lisant dégage
c'est c'est c'est la cohérence du
scénario c'est la beauté des personnages
qui sont autour c'est là c'est
l'atmosphère de ce que ça de ce que ça
des pins et j'ai trouvé dans ce dans ce
scénario en même temps une
un bonheur du dialogue très très rare au
cinéma un vrai dialogue un vrai dialogue
comme comme j'aurais pu le trouver pour
un très bel auteur de théâtre j'ai
tourné un très beau dialogue j'ai trouvé
aussi une une commande ya une structure
des séquences amenant vers le graphe
petit à petit mais toujours avec avec un
amusement toujours et puis ces deux
personnages qui sont autour qui
gravitent autour de monsieur charme et
qui sont là la jeune infirmière qui est
jouée par merveilleusement par gwenola
bothorel et catalifo qui joue l'autre
rôle du neveu et j'ai trouvé ces rôles
très très très savoureux très
intéressant très curieux et le choc de
cette génération de jeunes qui voient la
vie avec beaucoup d'optimisme et un
certain laisser-aller une certaine
drôlerie a accolé à ce personnage très
grave et est presque à la mort j'ai
trouvé ça très très intéressant comme
choc est alors je
j'ai eu le bonheur de rencontrer rocha
trois jours après le le producteur s'est
mis d'accord tout de suite et donc
j'étais heureux je suis reparti avec
mons et narration en tournée et j'ai
commencé à travailler dessus alors
justement vous tracks of quand vous
travaillez vous dites j'ai toujours pris
plaisir à décortiquer me rôle je suis un
maniaque un studieux ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'entre le scénario que
vous avez reçus et le scénario que vous
aviez sous le bras au début du tournage
il ya déjà des pages et des pages
d'annotations ah non pas du tout il ya
eu qu une annotation simplement c'est
des lectures successives et ses lectures
je les ai boules jeu
j'imagine le rôle d'une certaine manière
et puis j'ai bull je vais en chercher un
autre plus profond j'ai bull et et
cetera et cetera et cetera ça laisse des
traces et ce qui fait que à la fin à
prévoir et boulay beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup le personnage comme ça ils
avoir remplacé par par d'autres manières
de le voir
j'arrive à ne plus avoir besoin de jouer
de faire quelque chose avec je me laisse
envahir en quelque sorte par lui et il
tout toutes ses strates différente des
pauses quelque chose qui je crois est
visible à la pellicule sens que j'ai
besoin de 2
de le jouer à proprement parler c'est en
fait un exercice un exercice pour polir
et pour affiner et pour ne plus avoir à
m'en mêler je n'aime pas montrer quelque
chose que j'aurais voulu montrer j'aime
que le personnage me surprennent et
j'aime que le personnage soit une
surprise et me dit et me dicte très
exactement ce qu'il attend de moi
je me met à son service en quelque sort
mais on sent très bien que le personnage
est marqué et marque est définitivement
un que
c'est un personnage si vous voulez qu'il
ya un trajet à la beckett sans avoir
jamais lu beckett lippi qui se trouve
qu'ils se trouvent par la vie vivre une
aventure de minéralisation qu en quelque
sorte et qui la vie sans s'en rendre
compte comme monsieur jourdain faisait
de la prose
il fait lui du désespoir et il vit avec
et il trouve une raison de survivre
malgré ce désespoir dans un rôle comme
ça ça un rôle comme ça vous vous a fait
réfléchir sur votre propre mort c'est
une confrontation personnelle à ce type
de questionnement ou pas vraiment non je
n'ai pas plus réfléchi à ma mort
actuellement que je n'ai que je n'y
réfléchis depuis l'âge de 8 ans non j'y
réfléchis bien sûr j'y pense mais je
veux dire c'est une chose inconnue c'est
une chose mystérieuse complètement
inconnu qui peut exciter une certaine
curiosité et c'est que
cette curiosité je les jeux les prêter à
ce personnage ou et peut-être mais j'ai
surtout suivi ce qu'il avait à me dire
aux aiguilles au vous vous aviez obtenu
le césar du court métrage en 87 pour
laguna et
c'est vrai que ce film me frappe d'abord
par une originalité du scénario vraiment
vraiment étonnante par aussi une sorte
de parenté avec une grande tradition du
cinéma français vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la qualité des dialogues
l'attention à ce qu'on appelle les
seconds rôles aussi qui a été trop
longtemps la force du cinéma français
vous êtes pétri de ce cinéma là de
cinéma on sait pas on pense à renoir au
cinéma des années 30 40 je veux pas et
vous écraser sous les références mais on
y pense
oui j'aime bien je me souviens d'une
phrase de renoir dans french cancan
quand il jean gabin est absolument
submergé par ses dettes dans dans
l'hôtel il ya deux de ses comparses à
l'extérieur qu'ils disent qu'elle meure
la matière qui triomphe de l'esprit ou
pas si vous venez ça avec une faconde
incroyable bref vous dire voilà c'est le
sujet du film à l'envers alors en même
temps il ya plus il va triompher oui
alors sans vouloir en faire un film
manifeste il ya quand même une volonté
de de passer au crible cette sorte de
rapport d'hypocrisie et de dénégation
vis-à-vis de la mort le culte de la
jeunesse là la façon dont la mort est
totalement occulté et donc finalement la
société aujourd'hui ne veut plus la
regarder en face sites antiques
l'expression est un sens oui c'est à
dire que bon pour ce propos pour ses
personnages me dire je les essaie
d'aider cap et des capteurs iannacci
bull et l'autre qui décape
c'est à dire de de retirer des pouilles
et tout ce qui est des convenances tout
ce qui est un gros de la sentimentalité
toutes ces choses là pour aborder accru
le fait que quelqu'un va mourir et
quelques qu'un dauphin
monsieur charme donc michel qui a du
savoir vivre parce que s'il veut mourir
ce qu'il a du savoir vivre c'est
important ça fait partie de son savoir
vivre de refuser de vivre dans ce que
dans dans ce kit est proposé et donc les
autres eux ils vont à vouloir vivre à la
limite mais à vouloir vivre de façon
très matériel je veux dire un budget
comme çà de là l'accumulation et donc
ben j'ai fait affronte fin j'ai posé ces
deux personnages l'un avec l'autre l'un
contre l'autre si on veut on est
décapant de tous de vraiment de tout ce
qui peut être de la convenance et pas de
morale je viens d'un continent c'est à
dire tout ce qu'on peut imaginer de
larmes de violon de pleurs et cetera
pour aborder accrue quelque chose qui
est une vérité je dire qu'à une vérité
que tous on doit ressentir et autres
étant touchés par espèce de crudités de
cette vérité je pense qu'il ya une
jubilation absolument formidable on est
en époux ayant comme ça enfin moi j'aime
pas trop le réalisme le vraiment le
naturalisme au cinéma d'hier donc en
époux ayant comme ça je dire on touche à
des choses je veux dire qu'ils sont
propres et se dire qui réjouissent de
façon formidable parce que je savais ce
film en face et 1
vous savez un metteur en scène il recrée
demande enfin il recrée je veux dire que
les salles de cinéma c'est un petit peu
des temples et des temples qui sont
voués à dire création du monde par des
metteurs en scène est ce qui est
formidable c'est quand on sort d'un film
comme ça enfin j'ai le sentiment un
michel sait que dire on a touché des
vérités et que ces vérités ont fait
jubiler jeudi ronron ressort en posant
de façon frêche et de façon vigoureuse
le pied par terre dias et quand même
c'est ça qui est formidable mais je veux
dire c'est un une à son dauphin c'est
quelque chose c'est une ode au plaisir
de vivre c'est à dire
c'est un pied-de-nez un petit peu tout
les morbidité jeudi vous savez
comment dire je veux dire c'est vrai on
baigne la morbidité en ce moment où les
gens s'éparpillent je veux dire de leur
identité les ailes et elle est
totalement morcelé je veux dire il se
retrouve des boues d'identité sur les
choses qui sont un peu ridicules et
quand on propose bon comme consensus
veut dire comme consensus ben le trajet
de la vie bien à ce moment là c'est déjà
ça devient jubilant faire retrouve
quelque chose michelle brille vous avez
dans ce livre qui s'appelle la leçon de
comédie que vous avez publié il ya
quelques années d'un livre d'entretiens
avec jean jacques vincensini chez
seguier archimbaud
très beau livre assure sur votre
expérience de comédien de professeurs
aussi vous dit mattar hier une
succession de soubresauts de moment vous
n'avez jamais passé l'expression trajet
de vie qui me fait penser à ça ça a
toujours été une succession de choix qui
ne auquel vous ne vous attendiez pas
vous même la projection pas de cohérence
n'y a pas de cohérence non c'est
simplement des petites séquences
escorteur film de roger c'est des
petites séquences n'est ce pas qui sont
très importantes dans le moment où elles
elles sont là et puis qui font suite à
d'autres qui n'ont aucun rapport avec et
c'est une succession de petites
séquences de deux petits éclatement de
petites illuminations comme ça alors
j'ai rencontré à nouveau rencontrer
camus j'ai rencontré painter j'ai
rencontré dès que tu rencontré toutes
sortes de gens j'ai travaillé sur leurs
textes et et ç'a toujours été sans
rapport ç'a toujours été toujours
en fait un trajet assez merveilleux les
uns demandent qu à une sorte de
disponibilité à saisir l'occasion de la
rencontre une intuition une intuition se
servir de son intuition et après
travailler à partir de de l'état de
miracle qu'on a senti à être en face
quelqu'un ou avec l'oeuvre de quelqu'un
et d'essayer alors là de d'entretenir le
miracle de l'entretenir par le travail
pour rester avec lui pour rester le plus
possible avec lui et quand je joue un
auteur que ce soit guillot que ce soit
jaco van dormael si c'est au cinéma où
que ce soit grémillon que ce soit
chabrol j'essaie de pénétrer le plus
possible et de rester dans dans
l'émerveillement de l'univers du choc
j'ai reçu du choc émotionnel que j'ai
reçus
je vis comme ça curieusement ce qui sert
l'intuition c'est la réflexion je vous
cite encore michel bouquet donc dans le
film de régis guiot la joie type
[Musique]